nice nice yummy a smile camera stoic
just chill where did you get a good day
well I should I have my tea should have
my tea probably been sitting here for 15
minutes trying to figure out how to
intro this video so here's the intro to
the video I am Owen with MPW media I'm
Adam from fbw media and we're here to
talk about a video we recently did
called I am apex for timber products
company specifically there am pine
division and specifically when they came
to us about launching their new product
apex which is a composite panel product
we really worked hard and kind of
thought about how can we make that
visually interesting we decided to have
the story of the production of one of
these panels be told from the
perspective of the panel so we shot the
whole project on red we shot on a red
epic w and a red epic dragon what was
really interesting is that the mills are
really really really dark like you can
attested this insanely insanely dark so
we shot most of it at 3200 ISO I think
yeah that seems about right yeah which
is nuts and I mean it looked fantastic
shot up mostly on canons still glass
l-series lenses with the cinema lens
here they're thrown in I'd say it's an
artistic decision but it was also driven
by a necessity but it was really awesome
how it worked out was the lighting you
know we knew that going in lighting was
gonna be a huge problem we've shot in a
lot of Mills before so we decided to
embrace that lighting was gonna be a
challenge and actually physically show a
lot of our lights in the shots because
in the mills there's all sorts of
different lights that are different
bulbs different color temperatures and
we knew that we we're gonna have no
control over that
yeah cuz it a lot of the times it looks
like what we're shooting is a spot that
needs to be examined anyway so it could
be a light that's spotted on there for
specific reason right so probably one of
the hardest shots I would say from a
safety perspective and just
a planning perspective was our shots in
the furnished room where the dust comes
in and the furnish comes in to be made
into the board and the graded footage
you can't really tell but there it was
so dusty that when they were moving that
that was probably like a whiteout almost
I mean yeah
Adam basically was with me and I don't
actually know what you were behind me so
I had just I had one hand on your safety
vest just kind of pulling you around
making sure that you didn't run into
anything that if the loader was coming
at you we weren't too close and then at
one point your safety glasses fell off
and you must have just been filming
blindness and it basically was I mean it
was like I kind of knew where I could
see where the loader was and I could
kind of see with a camera but I was just
basically imagining the framing because
I couldn't even see the screen because
the screen got completely covered over a
dust at one point and so we were just
but it turned out really well yeah and
then as soon as it was over as soon as
it take was over it'd be us running out
putting the camera on on an on the stand
and then just I mean blowing it off like
crazy Oh No weird Adam go sitting here
with Jake our senior editor at fbw media
to talk about the post-production
process on ima fix Jake you want to kind
of take us through our last product shot
where we dip back into the narrative
yeah and sometimes it's great because
that one was actually really easy that
was kind of a move born out of the
camera movement and then all I had to do
was really dip to black there and just
pay close attention to where we were
making the actual cut in both of those
when we kind of threw a curveball and
now in a little bit because that part of
the project wasn't shot until almost the
whole edit was done I would say yeah so
you had this kind of gaping hole for
most of the Edit of where those product
shots were supposedly connected and
those were also kind of fun because we
had a lot of visual effects to cover
things that we couldn't get in camera so
you added more fire more fire in the
studio it's kind of hard to not light
things on fire right right and then
the moisture scene did you add more a
couple layers in front or had I added
some layers of smoke in front and then I
masked out the actual piece and added a
couple behind it to give it that sense
of depth that it has all in all I think
it's one of the projects that I'm most
proud of and we had a blast film in it
if anybody has any questions about the
production or the gear we use or
anything like that please reach out to
us and make sure to watch the video in
full thanks for watching
you